Schauen wir an.
Guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag, Karat.
Ich bin der, mein Name ist Semle Gökstas.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen,
bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, okay?
Gerne.
Okay.
Erst mal, wie heißen Sie?
Thomas Müller.
So einfach.
Ja.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
75 Jahre alt.
Und raten Sie mir bitte Ihr Geburtsdatum?
Das ist denn der 5., 6., 1905.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
180.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg.
Herr Müller, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich war Mechaniker.
Aber ich bin jetzt zu Hause jetzt.
Genieße meine Leben.
Genau.
Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Sie sind schon groß, 2.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
2 Kinder.
Ah, 2 Kinder haben Sie, okay.
Ja.
So, Herr Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich wollte auch nicht kommen.
Meine Frau hat mich sozusagen gepusht,
dass ich ins Krankenhaus gehen soll.
Weil ich in der letzten Zeit stark schlappe und müde bin.
Und ja, habe ich keinen Appatit.
Ich würde nicht sagen, aber weniger Appetit.
Und zu dem, ja, da sind halt so die Sachen,
wo ich zu Hause keine Leistung mehr habe.
Also, die Leistung ist ganz schlecht.
Für sich nicht, dass ich keine Lust habe,
sondern auch, weil ich keine Kraft habe.
Ich verstehe.
Daraufhin hat natürlich meine Frau es besorgt.
Und hat gesagt, ich muss mal ins Krankenhaus.
Vor allem am Wochenende,
da habe ich gesagt, lass mich am Montag zum Haushalt gehen.
Da hat sie gesagt, nee, du bist faul, du gehst nicht zum Haushalt.
Geh mal ins Notaufnahmen.
Ich habe gesagt, okay.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Seit wann fühlen Sie sich müde?
Mhm.
Das kann meine Frau gut beantworten, aber besser.
Aber ich würde einschätzen,
dass Sie sich seit ungefähr seit 4 Wochen ungefähr?
Seit 4 Wochen.
Aber zu nehmen, ja.
Das ist nicht, dass ich seit 4 Wochen ganz müde bin.
Das ist aber in der letzten Zeit zu nehmen.
Ich verstehe, okay.
Und haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerde,
wie eine Schmerzenübelkeit oder Schwindel?
Nein.
Eigentlich habe ich keine Symptome außerdem.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit erbrochen?
Noch mal bitte.
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe wieder eine Übelkeit noch erbrochen gehabt.
Okay.
Und haben Sie bemerkt,
ob Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verloren oder zunehmend zugenommen?
Ich habe so eine Abgenommen.
Ich schütze mal ungefähr 5 kg ein.
In welcher Zeitraum haben Sie 5 kg abgenommen?
Ja, so ungefähr in 2 Monaten.
2 Monate.
Haben Sie höchsten Atemnot?
Nein, selbst in Druckgefühlen im Hals.
Wo genau? Hals.
Sie sehen zu meiner Rechte,
Hals ist auch etwas geschwollen.
Sehen Sie das?
Ja.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, seit wann haben Sie geschwollene Hals?
Seit ungefähr 2 Wochen.
Seit 2 Wochen.
Aber zu nehmen, das muss ich sagen.
Es ist nicht, dass vor 2 Wochen war, so wie jetzt war,
sondern hat so langsam, langsam gestartet und geschwollene.
Okay.
Und gibt es dabei Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, wirklich kann ich sagen, nein, keine Schluckbeschwerden.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Nachschweiß?
Leiden Sie unter Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß habe ich auch in der letzten Zeit.
Aber nicht so viel.
Es ist etwas mehr als sonst.
Viel hat ich nie gehabt.
Könnten Sie mir genau beschreiben, wie die Nachschweiß sind?
Ich meine, wie viel schwitzen Sie in der Nacht?
Ob ich meine Unterhämter wechseln soll.
Ob ich meine Unterhämter wechseln soll oder nicht?
Unterwäsche.
Dass es nicht so so stark ist, dass ich meine Unterwäsche wechseln soll.
Aber es ist schon vermehrt, ja, muss man sagen.
Dass ich muss in der Nacht einmal aufstehen.
Man muss auch sagen, habe ich Durst noch, dass ich nach nach muss aufstehen und trinken,
weil ich schwitze manchmal.
Als ich Fieber habe, aber da habe ich keine Fieber.
Mir ist warm.
Und ja, so kann ich das beschreiben.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen, die Temperatur gemessen?
Ob ich meine Temperatur gemessen habe.
Wir haben es auch aus einer Gerät.
Ich gehe davon aus, es ist kaputt.
Es messt das nicht richtig.
Aber Ihnen ist warm, ja?
War warm, aber nicht so, dass ich sage, dass ich Fieber hatte.
Manchmal, wenn Sie schnell laufen, fühlen Sie sich so ein bisschen warm.
Ein bisschen anders.
Und das ist so, dass diese die gleichen Gefühle.
Ich verstehe.
Okay.
Müssen Sie in der letzten Zeit oft zur Toilette gehen?
Ja, ein.
Was meinen Sie? Ja, mit Jaen.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Als Sie gesagt haben, weil ich in der Nacht viel trinken soll,
in der Nacht muss ich schon zweimal gehen.
Tagsüber trinke ich schon, aber zwei Liter.
Und gehe ich jetzt ja, es ist etwas mehr als ein Sonsten,
aber würde ich sagen, ja, es ist nicht so genau ausgeprägt,
wie ich jetzt sagen, ja, direkt.
Okay, gibt es keine Veränderungen beim Wasserlassen?
Okay.
Sind Sie da?
Ja, können Sie mich hören?
Hallo?
Ja, letzte Mal für Wasserlassen.
Wasserlassen.
Und ich habe es erklärt.
Okay, ja, das klar.
Und Sie haben geschworen.
Ja, und haben Sie Haut, haben,
Farbeveränderungen?
Farbeveränderungen, ja,
und der Haut?
Nee, eigentlich, ja, habe ich nicht gespürt oder gesehen.
Auch wieder von meiner Frau habe ich auch nichts gehört.
Also, das hat Sie, hat Sie das gesagt.
Okay, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen zu aktuellen Beschwerden?
Nee, ich will mal gerne wissen,
dass ich meine Frau beruhigen kann und zu sagen,
hier habe ich gar nichts, ich kann wieder kommen.
Ja, erst mal möchte ich noch ein paar Fragen
über Ihre Vorerkrankungen und Familiengeschichte etwas fragen.
Danach sprechen wir noch mal, okay?
Alles klar.
Leiden Sie unter chronischen Erkrankungen oder Vorerkrankungen?
Ob ich Vorerkrankungen habe?
Genau.
Nee, eigentlich, außer Blutdurchdruck,
habe ich immer so ein Medikament genommen
und nehme mich immer auch weiterhin ein.
Das heißt am Lutipin.
Ansonsten hatte ich nie Probleme gehabt.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdurchdruck?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ich habe so ein Problem, ja, so ein Katarakt.
Ich weiß, das war auch aus Graustahl, genau, so war das.
Und das war fünf Jahren auch.
Operiert?
Ja.
Würden Sie operiert?
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie Schwere oder wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Meine Eltern leben noch nicht mehr, natürlich.
Aber, was die hatten, jetzt kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Aber damals gab es nicht so viele, auch, dass man das zu finden,
was wir es hatten, aber die sind verstorben schon.
Okay, wissen Sie, woran?
Woran, wo die sind verstorben?
Schwierig zu beantworten.
Meine Vater war schon über 80 Jahre alt, als er verstorben war.
Da hat er auch so eine Probleme gehabt, schon mit dem Organen.
Die haben gesagt, dass er eine Tumor ist.
Und am Ende hat meine Vater alle weitere Maßnahmen abgedehnt.
Und wollte nicht weit untersuchen, veranlassen.
Am Ende ist er mit einer medizinischen Hausbegleitung entlassen worden.
Und ist zu Hause verstorben.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was er hatte.
Er wollte damals nicht wissen, was er hatte.
Er ist in dem Main, die muss ihn weiter machen.
Er hat recht gehabt.
Okay, ein Moment.
Sie haben wegen nählicher Wasserlassen durch Schlafstörungen.
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich habe so ein Durstgefühl.
Ich stehe auch im Trink.
Ich habe uns zu schwitzen.
Ich habe jeden Tag.
Das ist vielleicht dreimal pro Woche.
Das ist wie eine Tappe.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie siehlich belastet?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit oder in der Familie?
Aktuell nicht.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich nehme nichts ein.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Vorher haben Sie nie geraucht?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu.
Was meinen Sie?
Ich habe jeden Tag einen Bier.
Das ist normal.
Glaswein mit meiner Frau oder Freundin.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nie genommen.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt?
Auf der Allergie habe ich eine Bekannte.
Nein, das ist auch nicht bekannt.
Ich habe keine Allergie gehabt.
Herr Müller, habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte wissen, was ich habe und was ich noch machen muss.
Ob ich die Diagnose bekommen kann,
dass ich entlassen werden kann oder nicht.
Herr Müller, ich kann nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Ich muss die Untersuchungen durchführen,
um die richtige Diagnose festzustellen.
Nach der Ergebnisse,
können wir etwas sagen.
Sie sollten heute bei uns bleiben.
Ich würde Sie erst einmal körperlich untersuchen.
Danach nehmen Sie den Blut ab.
Ich möchte die Anschwellungen am Hals überprüfen.
Nach der Ergebnisse besprechen wir noch einmal.
Ich bleibe hier in der Notaufnahme.
Sie können im Arzt warten.
Ich komme Ihnen gleich.
Ich habe die Patienten vorgestellt.
Wir können das weiter machen.
Hier in der Gruppe gibt es Fragen.
Haben wir alles gefragt,
dass wir die Fragen haben müssen?
Ich habe die Druckgefühle im Bauch.
Wo noch mal bitte?
Im Bauch.
Ich habe keine Druckgefühle mehr.
Ich habe die jukreis.
Ich habe die jukreis schon gefragt.
Es ist nicht so ausgeprägt.
Es gibt eine schöne Frage.
Ich habe die Analyse von Frau Nalan.
Sie haben eine Schwindelung im Halsbereich.
Es gibt eine andere Schwellung.
Ich habe nicht so viel gespürt.
Ich habe die Unterarmung getragen.
Das ist unter die rechte Arm.
Das ist ohne Schmerzen.
Die Unterarmung ist ohne Schmerzen.
Ich habe nie Schmerzen gehabt.
Ich dachte, es ist vielleicht so eine Schwillung durch den ...
... Zunahme oder durch eine Entzündung,
das ich vielleicht hatte, was ich nicht wusste.
Wir haben so eine Umgebung, Freunde, die Arzt auch sind,
Älsten sind und die meinen, dass Muskeln, Muskeln,
sie mal zu Hause beobachten, das kann auch weggehen.
Aber Anversicht, das Problem hat sich ...
nicht gelöst und es vermehrt.
Und daraufhin bin ich jetzt ...
in der Notaufnahme.
Okay.
Und ich habe verpasst, was war Ihre Vater's Krebs?
Das weiß ich nicht genau, ob der Krebs hatte oder nicht,
aber der hatte so fast der Habt Auffindiges.
Und die Älsten wollten das noch untersuchen,
Proben nehmen, aber am Ende meiner Vater hat sich der Gegner
entschieden und hat gesagt, auch wenn ich Krebs habe,
ich will es nicht wissen und ich will einfach sterben,
in Ruhe.
Und es ...
wieder entlassen worden damals auch und ...
über mit einem ästlichen Begleitung und zu Hause ist eingeschlafen.
Wo hat es Ihre ... Mutter gestorben?
Ja, der hat so einen Autounfall gehabt.
Autoun.
Und ist Ihnen ... Heiserkeit aufgefallen?
Nee, eigentlich auch nicht.
Aber auch gute Frage.
Sind diese Schöpfe?
Erschöpfe.
Ja, bitte, ich erheße.
Waren Sie erschöpft durch die Alltagsaktivität?
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, warum ich hier gekommen bin.
Weil ich geschickt bin von meiner Frau.
Äh ...
dass ich im Alltag ...
so stark schlapp bin und ...
schnell äh ... antrieblos bin, so zu sagen.
Äh, oder müde bin, daraufhin.
Meine Frau hat gesagt, das kann nicht jetzt so lange dauern,
oder so, ob Sie auch, soll ich das auch nicht mehr durchhalten.
Jetzt müssen Sie das creme, was ich jetzt noch habe,
warum ich so schnell äh ...
nur da werden.
Sind die Schwellungen sehr hart oder weich?
Hm.
Hm, an der Sicht von meinem Aspekt, dass es nicht so hart ist,
was heißt hart, was heißt es?
Äh, das kann ich nicht unterscheiden, dass wenn Sie gucken, genau.
Okay, und können Sie die Schwellungen mit Hand bewegen?
Oder das ist ja stabil?
Das ist ja stabil, ja, ich kann es nicht bewegen.
Okay, danke.
Ist auch guter Frage.
Ja, gut.
Noch?
Haben Sie Franz-Körpe-Gefühl im Haar oder Globus-Gefühl?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht. Die Kollegin hat auch gefragt,
ob ich Schluck beschwenk habe.
Äh, ich habe die Gefühle auch nicht, eigentlich.
Haben Sie Husten?
Äh, auch guter Frage.
Nee, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Haut-Yuken?
Äh, das hat die Kollegin gefragt.
Ja.
Da gibt es noch Fragen, die Sie stellen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, wenn ich mich belaste, natürlich ja normal.
Weil ich keine Kraft habe.
Ich gehe davon, dass es normal ist.
Herr Münder, das sollen Sie entscheiden, ob das normal ist.
Haben Sie etwas gefragt wegen Ernährung?
Nein, habe ich nur, Sie haben gesagt, äh, ich, äh, keine Appetit habe,
aber ich muss, äh, noch, äh, ein bisschen detaillieren vielleicht.
Äh, äh, wie ernähren Sie sich oder seit wann haben Sie keine Appetit?
Kann man fragen?
Nee, genau.
Appetit ist an für Sie seit drei, vier Wochen schlecht.
Aber ich nehme ab und zu so pflanzliche Sachen und Nachbarn,
die mich auch empfohlen haben, vielleicht ich das erkältet bin
und, ähm, das hilft auch manchmal.
Die hatten auch so ein Schwelch und Hals gehabt nach seiner Erkältung
und die meint, das ist halt normal.
Und daraufhin habe ich auch auch nicht das Wahl genommen
und eins genommen, so zu sagen.
Aber die haben etwas empfohlen, was die gekauft haben und benutzt haben.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau der Inhalt, aber ich habe es auch genommen.
Eigentlich hat nicht geholfen.
Sie haben pflanzliche Sachen äh, zu schieben?
Ja, so eine Tee, genau, Tee oder äh.
Bist du Sie, was war, äh, was war das?
Nee, jetzt eine Mischung von unterschiedlichen Pflanzen, aber
das muss ich meine Frau jetzt anrufen und dann Fotos davon schicken lassen,
was das war.
Das wäre super, okay.
Mhm.
Okay.
Ich glaub, sind wir durch, oder?
Ja.
Aber ihr seid alle äh, äh toll, muss ich sagen.
Jede Frage hat eine...
Grund.
Bedeutung und äh, Bedeutung, genau.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter jetzt.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Obererz.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen, einen, einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Kurzzeit?
Ja, gerne.
Äh, Thomas, äh, es geht um Thomas Müller, äh, und ist 75-Jahregen, äh, jahrege Patienten.
Äh, er ist Mecher, äh, er war Mechaniker und hat zwei Kinder.
Mhm.
Er klagt über abgeschlagenheit seit vier Wochen.
Und äh, und äh, Appetitlosigkeit.
Mhm.
Äh, diese Beschwerden äh, sind, diese Beschwerden äh, sind in der, äh, im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert.
Ähm, und er hat in der zwei Monaten fünf Kilo abgenommen.
Mhm.
Er hat auch ähm, Kraftlosigkeit und, als, äh, und er erwähnt, dass er ein, äh, Hals, äh, ein, äh, Schwillung, ein Odeum, an, äh, an der, an den, an dem Halsbereich.
Seit zwei Wochen.
Und sie, äh, leidend, leidet auch unter Nachschweiß, äh, Hiperhydrose und hat, äh, Drustgefühl.
Mhm.
Ja, und äh, sie, äh, fühle, äh, unter, unter, in Achselerbereich, äh, äh, gab der Patient an zwei, äh, Modulus an.
In der Vorerkrankungen liegt arteriale Hypertonie seit, äh, fünf Jahren und nimmt dagegen am Lodipin ein.
Äh, verteilische Seite, äh, der Familienanämnese, Anämnese liegt verteilische Seite, äh, ein, äh, Tumorgeschichte vor, aber der Patient weiß nicht genau, was das ist, was das war.
Aber das war verdacht, deine Tumorgeschichte, das nicht das Tumor.
Genau, nein, ja, ja, das ist nicht, äh, bestätigt.
Das ist, ja, das hat nicht bestätigt, das ist eine Verdachtgeschichte.
Mhm.
Und, ja, äh, vegetative Anämnese, äh, der Patient, äh, dem Patient ist, äh, warm.
Und hat keine Appetit und in der, in der letzte Zeit gegen, äh, in der letzte, in der letzte Zeit hat sie pflanzliche Sache zu sich genommen.
Mhm.
Aber äh, er weiß nicht, äh, was das ist.
Äh, und er ist nicht raucher, äh, trinkt jeden Tag ein Fleisch Bier am Wochenende, äh,
gelegenstisch Schwein.
Mhm.
Sonst äh, die sind die Besperren.
Was wir vergessen haben, äh, Nese noch Auslandweiden, ne?
Genau.
Ja.
Das wird nicht jetzt sein.
Okay.
Das ist auch richtig, aber es ist jetzt spät.
Ja, während der Untersuchung äh, frage ich mich nochmal.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Ja, was, was, was äh, denken Sie, was er hat oder was will ich als Nekkes machen?
Äh, ja, äh, der, der Patient hat äh, Gewichtverlust und ein Abgeschlagenheit, Nachschweiß und äh, wir haben noch nicht äh, das Fieber gemisten, aber dann ein Fieber sein äh,
er kann ein Fieber haben, äh, deswegen äh, er hat Betasymptomatik und Gewichtverlust, deswegen äh, nach den bisherigen Angaben geh ich von einem Karzinom äh aus.
Äh, ja, er hat auch an äh, Halsschwillungen, äh, das kann ein äh, Larings Karzinom sein, weil äh, er hat keine Schluckstörung, äh,
deswegen äh, äh, ich, äh, äh, keine Schluckstörung, äh, beschwerden, äh, sprechen, äh, dagegen,
mit richtig Augen schauen.
Ja.
Er hat auch, er hat auch Axilära-Lymphnoten.
Axilära-Lymphnoten, ja.
Ja.
Und ja, das ist auch noch eine äh, bei Larings, bei Larings ist es unwahrscheinlich, wenn das ein Axilära-Lymphnoten bekommt.
Ach so, okay.
Bei dieser Frage ist es auch unwahrscheinlich.
Bei Magern, ja, bei dieser Frage ist es nicht.
Mhm.
Ja, schon, aber er, sehr selten, aber, wir fangen mit ihm häufig an jetzt.
75 Jahre alt, ja.
Genau.
Äh, muss man nicht vergessen, mit äh, äh, nicht schmerzhaftes äh, Knoten und mit Basyntomatik,
stellt sie sich in den Notaufnahmen vor.
Ja.
Und ähm, bevor sie jetzt weitergehen, die Kollegen sind gleich in der Gruppe, die schreiben,
alle, die hat Moser, was, was eigentlich passend können, äh, aber sie sonst nicht lesen,
und so ist das den Tipps für sie in der Prüf.
Dann ich schließe die Chat.
Genau.
Äh, da sind ähm, sie, sie sollen jetzt als Schritt bei Schritt jetzt, sie haben jetzt mal
Körperuntersuchen durchzuführen.
Was müssen sie darauf achten?
Sie müssen erst mal an die keine Diagnose denken, erst mal, was denken sie,
als erstes, wenn sie seine Patientin haben, was sich achten mussten,
bei, bei dem Körperuntersuchen, was würd ich machen?
Erst mal Inspektion. Ich muss äh, den Hals untersuchen.
Genau.
Äh, wenn äh, gibt es eine äh, Lämpherdönopathie, Lämpherdönitis oder
Tonzylitis gibt. Ja.
Genau.
Äh, danach ich muss äh, ein äh, den Hals abtasten.
Äh, diese Anschwellung muss ich äh, lokalisieren, äh, gibt es äh,
Theroid äh, äh, irgendetwas äh, und sie können es auch so einfach beschreiben.
Ich würde es einfach lokalisieren, denn die äh, Schwellung einfach äh,
äh, äh, erfassen, wo das ist, ja.
Sie müssen nicht so viel oder auch, oder auch, weit tief gehen,
weil, wenn sie viel beschreiben, dann machen sie viel Fehler.
In der Prüfung versuchen sie, mass kurz und zusammenfassend zu beschreiben.
Ansonsten äh, die Prüfer versuchen, da meine Fehler zu finden,
und dann sagt ihr, weshalb jetzt Theroid, was, was zu tun hat mit dem,
wie, wie können sie das tassen, ja?
Dann sagen sie, ja, und dann können sie nicht beantworten.
Ja.
Da verbrauchst du eine Ultraschall, dann sagt man, ja.
Und deswegen geht sie nicht an der Organe, sagt sie,
ich, Schwellung gesehen, ich will einfach die lokalisation,
genau im Fassum ist es ein, ein stabiles, es ist ein immobilis Schwellung,
es ist, es ist hart, ich will einfach an die äh,
äh, Konstentenz von den äh, Schwellung einfach achten,
wie das ist, wie das aussieht, ja?
Mhm.
Für sie nur als Tipps in der Prüfung, machen sie weiter,
sie sind ein richtiger Weg jetzt, ja?
Okay.
Äh, ja, erstmal äh, die, äh, die Anschwellung, ich äh, möchte,
ich würde die Anschwellung lokalisieren.
Danach äh, danach äh, kann ich ein,
äh, kann ich ein Blut abnehmen?
Reicht es aus mit Köpfe untersuchen?
Köpfe untersuchen.
Machen sie nichts weiter?
Äh, ja, erst, äh, und die Aksäleerbereich,
Lämpfknoten abtasten.
Sehr gut, sie haben getastet,
der rechte Aksäleer hat zwei Lämpfknoten.
Okay.
Weiter?
Und äh, ja, äh, weiter, äh, ich möchte die Bauch...
Guck mal, wenn man die Chat lest, dann macht das alles, ja.
Bauch, äh, Bauch äh, äh, abtasten.
Ja, warum?
Weil ich muss äh, die, äh, Leber- und Milz-
äh, untersuchen, damit äh, der Patient hat,
ein Vergrößerung äh, Zipflinomegalie
oder Hepatomegalie äh, hat.
Genau.
Ja, das, sie haben ja seine Vermutung, ja.
Ja.
Sie, anhand dieser Vermutung, sie machen ihre Untersuchungen,
ja.
Genau.
Jetzt ist gut, du tippst okay sehr toll, machen sie es toll.
Jetzt weiter?
Äh, ja, abtasten Perkution, äh, das ist auch wichtig.
Und für die äh,
und noch äh,
Armuntersuchung kann ich machen,
ob der Patient ein,
der hat unter Arm und ja, das brauchen sie nicht.
Da, sehen Sie, können Sie machen, aber Sie können vieles machen.
Aber Sie sollen sich anhand der in einer Medias konzentrieren
und entsprechen auch Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wir haben jetzt den Hals-Lift-Kulum getastet,
Sie haben den Axilium-Kulum getastet,
Sie haben den Ordan,
hat Bauch-Äh, Untersuchungen durchgeführt,
eine Espiline-Megalie hat eine Megalie ausgeschließen.
Ja.
Auch seine Lymphknoten,
äh, so die, die man auch,
vielleicht so große Lymphknoten, die man auch tassen können,
im Bauchfeld,
das ist selten zu sehen.
Das noch,
als Lymphkulutregion zu tassen, was ist das?
Der letzte?
Ja, das letzte Regio.
Im grünal.
Im grünal Lymphknoten,
Halsbereich und Axilär, ja.
Das heißt, wir fangen von oben an.
Hals, Axilär und Ingrinal leisten.
Genau.
Superklavikulär ist auch,
gehört dazu, dass wenn man der Hals,
haste das Superklavikulär, muss man auch machen.
Das fangen wir von hier an,
äh, zusammen.
Und dann geht man unter Weiteraxilär.
Sie haben Organe geguckt
und sie haben Ingrinale geschaut,
oder reicht das aus?
Okay.
Sie haben gesehen,
dass der Patient eine
Spidiumigalie hat.
Mindestens anhand ihrer Körperuntersuchung.
Was heißt, was normal ist?
Großes Milch, wissen Sie das?
Oder so eine Körpisch?
Unter der Rippen?
Langgestrick, wie lang muss das sein?
Wenn Sie Unterstell machen
und einmal Schalkopf draufhalten.
8.
Ja, 10 bis 11.
Ja, das ist normal.
Daher,
Sie haben es gemessen, das war 13 cm.
Also eine Spidiumigalie hat.
Okay.
Ja, und was machen Sie noch als Nächstes?
Äh,
haben wir, habe ich Ultraschall gemacht?
Ja, auch nicht.
Sie sind jetzt beim Körperuntersuchung durchgeführt.
Jetzt machen Sie als Nächstes.
Was machen Sie als Nächstes?
Als Nächstes
kann ich Labo untersuchen
und Ultraschall.
Was achten Sie beim Blutuntersuchung?
Blutuntersuchung,
können wir Anämie?
Ja, genau.
finden
und
Sie gucken nur an der Anämie?
Oder haben Sie noch etwas?
Großes Blutbild,
erst mal.
Ja, Sie machen ein großes Blutbild.
Was wollen Sie da schauen?
Was wollen Sie darauf achten?
Anämie
und
Lempostos?
Da müssen Sie nicht haben,
dann können Sie auch haben.
Das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Sie können Lymphostose sehen,
aber wenn Sie den,
keiner sehen, das heißt nicht,
dass Sie eine Lymphom
oder Lymphorganekrankung ausgeschlossen haben.
Aber Sie machen trotzdem
eine Blutblut,
wie Sie das gesagt haben.
Sie wollen die Leukosythinasein
sehen, ob die Leukostythose
nicht hat.
Leukopamine
oder Leukostythose?
Leukopamine.
Weil,
weshalb machen Sie das?
Wenn Sie eine Vermutung von Dachs
bei dem Fum haben,
bei dem Fum-Passion
zwischen 10-15%
haben wir auch Klochenmark-Supposition.
Ja,
wenn man Klochenmark-Supposition hat,
was passiert denn?
Dann sieht man anhand der Blutbild,
dass die Passion leukopenytropin ist.
Oder pancytopin ist.
Aber dann sagen Sie,
was ist das hier,
Passion hat dem Fum und pancytopin.
Sprich das dagegen,
man normalerweise.
Aber in diesem Fall
muss man es auch Klochenmark machen.
Aber wir gehen nicht jetzt auftisch jetzt rein.
Wir bleiben bei unserer Basis.
Sie machen große Blutwelt
einfach,
diese drei Reier zu sehen.
Ja, die weißen Blutgärmschen,
der rote Blutgärmschen,
haben Sie es gesehen.
Und da war keine Auffälligkeiten zu erfassen.
Was machen Sie
noch beim Blutn dersuchen?
Entzündung.
Okay, ist auch nicht schlimm, machen Sie das auch, weil Sie geschwollene Lymphknoten haben, ob Sie eine Entzündung, einen Infekt haben, wollen Sie mir das auch auswischen?
Das ist auch richtig. Was würden Sie abnehmen bei Entzündung, Parameter?
CRP, noch Erritrosizidmentationen?
Ja, das ist auch richtig, genau. Das machen Sie auch, bis Sie GR, sagt man das, und was noch? Mehr haben Sie nicht.
Leukosiz, ja und...
Wir haben schon.
Ja, wir geben noch mal. Und was machen Sie noch jetzt in der Blu-Wemel und untersuchen, wenn wir da schon was wichtig ist?
Die Kollegin hat gerade geschrieben, eine Art for everyone, LDH, das ist eine richtige Marker.
Ja, bei Lymphom muss man unbedingt das machen, wenn man fragt, ob es die LDH ist oder nicht.
Wenn das hoch ist mit Lymphknoten, sagt man, das ist 90 Prozent Lymphom, man geht davon aus.
Aber das ist nicht eine Diagnostiskriterien, das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Was ist denn der nächste Schritt? Sie haben Blutgruppe, jetzt weiter, Sie brauchen auch die Leberwerte,
Sie brauchen auch den Grinnungs-Auch, Sie brauchen auch die Nierenwerte, das haben Sie nicht vergessen.
Für Sie als Tipps für die ganzen Kollegen, Blutuntersuchung, die ganzen Organen immer im Blick halten.
Ja, das ist sehr standard, ja, große Routine, sagt ihr immer, nicht große Blutwerte, große Routine.
Große Routine haben Sie große Blutwerte, Sie haben Nierenwerte, Sie haben Leberwerte, Sie haben Schildrusewerte,
Sie haben auch Albumine, Sie haben zudem Enzinnungwerte.
Das heißt, in der großen Routine haben Sie alles drin in der Paket.
Das ist man schon unterschiedlich, jeder Haus ist anders, aber das soll auch erwähnen.
Ich mache eine große Blut, große Routine und dann die Enhalt von großer Routine sind diese Sachen, was ich gesählt habe.
Und dann für die Prüfer wird das so, okay, der hat einen Blick auf alle Organen, das man hat alles jetzt geachtet, sehr gut, machen wir weiter.
Okay, was machen Sie als nächstes jetzt?
Hals-Ultrasphonografie.
Das ist auch nicht verkehrt, kann man machen, nur Hals-Ultraschein oder?
Nein, auch Abdomen, Hals.
Hals-Abdomen, richtig, was zielen Sie damit? Was wollen Sie erreichen mit dem Ultraschein?
Ultraschein können wir direkt der Milz- und Leber untersuchen und können wir die Anschwellung beschreiben,
die Grenze solide oder gibt es in Flüssigkeit drin?
Das heißt, Sie wollen Mittel-Ultraschein, die große des Milz- und Leber anschauen und messen auch.
Sie wollen eine freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch ausschließen, das ist Ihre Aussage,
bestimmt, dass Sie sagen wollten, oder?
Ja, können wir das machen, ja.
Sie können Mittel-Ultraschein eine intra-abdominale Limp-Roten oder Limp-Rendepathie auch sehen oder feststehen, das ist auch wichtig.
Sie können auch mit einem Ultraschein ein Promosa, intra-abdominale, ein Rahm-Gelimpfum,
aber so tief müssen Sie nicht wissen, Hauptsache, dass Sie sagen, warum ich Ultraschein mache, weshalb.
Die Ziel des Ultrascheins ist, dass die Organen einfach so schauen.
Ist das Ultraschein eine Entschlussuntersuchung? Nein.
Nein.
Das ist eine Ausschlussuntersuchung, aber es ist ein Mittel, das mitgesiebt wird.
Aber bei dem Form der Standarduntersuchung ist, nebenbei Blut, nebenbei Körperuntersuchung, ST.
Das ist gute Standard.
Dann macht man den CT von Hals, Torax und Abdomen.
Dann hat man alles drin.
Als nächstes, wie Sie jetzt gesagt haben, Sie haben jetzt Blut, Untersuchte, Körperuntersuchte, Sonografie gemacht.
Und als nächstes machen CT.
Wir gehen nicht tief in den Diagnostik rein, CT 20 oder PCL-Marker, das müssen Sie nicht wissen.
Aber das könnte im Prüfung gefragt werden, weil CT 20 als Limfohrmarker, PCL-Marker, wird gefragt, wenn das kommt.
Weil in Deutschland natürlich, die Piotler, die kennen das auch, weil die Frisch sind natürlich, die fragen,
was ist das für CT-Marker, was würden Sie das untersuchen.
CT 20 sagt man sofort, das soll jeder kennen.
CT 20 ist das Standard, das man macht bei PC-Limfohren.
Aber wenn man so vermutet, trotzdem bei dem Prüfung Verdachten machen Sie CT 20, das ist nicht CT 20, sondern Sie alleine.
Da gibt es noch mehrere Parameter, dann Mark, PCL, so weiter und weiter.
Da gibt es viele Mutations, die noch einmal erfassen sollen.
Aber erst mal CT 20, sondern Sie nicht vergessen, dass das machen soll.
Okay, Sie haben CT gemacht, CT 20 haben Sie es gesehen, dass das im Prüfung da ist.
Was machen Sie als nächstes?
Biobsi? Brauchen Biobsi?
Ja, wir machen Sie die Biobsi.
Ich würde im Grunde auch fragen, was wenn die Kollegen wenig nicht beantwortet, das soll im Grunde auch beantworten.
Okay.
Biobsi von Leibnizkopi oder?
BG for to everyone hat richtig beantwortet.
Leibnizkopi.
Leibnizkopi, das heißt man nimmt den Limfknoten total raus.
Bei dem Prüfung Verdacht, wenn Sie Biobsieren, kann sein, dass auch wahrscheinlich, dass die Limfzellen überhaupt nicht getroffen haben.
Und daher sagt man, sollen Sie einfach existieren, einfach entnehmen.
Entnehmen einfach, sagen Sie, nicht, Herr Dominik kann man auch sagen, entnehmen des Limfknoten, einfach den gesamten Limfnoten.
Und da ist das die Diagnostik und dann schicken Sie direkt zur histologischen Untersuchung.
Das ist auch der Standard Gold, den man machen muss.
Und anhand dem, die werden dann weiter molekular untersucht und im Unistischemie zu Pisierung wird gemacht.
Und dann erinnert die Pathologin, in scheiß welcher Art von Limfknoten ist und wie man das umgeht damit.
Und wie man dann behandelt.
Weil Biobsilimfknoten ist anders, Biobsilimfknoten ist anders.
Biobsilimfknoten hat man viele Intifitäten, viele Gruppe.
Und daher, das muss man anschauen.
Ansonsten, ja.
Entschuldigung, wie kann eine Frage, welche Leifknoten soll man erstmal entnehmen?
Und wie?
Einfachste Limfknoten, wo sie unter die Haut steht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie im Hals sehen, das ist der Einfachste.
Sie können nicht in kapdominanter Limfknoten raus, das ist nicht einfach.
Dafür brauchen Sie eine Laproskopie.
Und man versucht, eine einfachste Region zu finden, wo man das Besuch machen soll,
um den CT-Untersuchung zu sehen, wo die Limfknoten sind,
so mal axuell Limfknoten, einfach zu entfernen, zu entnehmen.
Oder die Halslimfknoten, der Einfachste, die man auch entfernen kann.
Manchmal, wie sagen auch in kapdominal, manche Konkurrenzlamalate, Limfknoten groß,
einzeln im ganzen Bauch, dann negern die Limfknoten, dann sagen die Radiologen,
machen Sie, wird das CT gesteuert.
Warum CT gesteuert?
Weil die gehen zehnmal da rein und nehmen mehr Rebiobsiden.
Die Limfknoten können Sie nicht kaltes rausnehmen, manchmal misst sie halt so.
Aber wenn sie das Einfachste, wo sie sitzt, dann sollen sie einfach rausnehmen.
Das macht den Chirurgien einmal, oder die haben Ruhien, das im Hals ist,
aber egal, manchmal machen wir auch selbst, wenn das Ganze unter der Haut ist
oder näher ist.
Ansonsten, ja, so ist das.
Aber die Limfknotenmetastasen, das sonst auch wissen, welche Limfknoten,
bei welcher Krankung, ich weiß nicht, ob es noch in der Prüfung bei Ihnen
freier kommt, aber das müssen Sie aber so grob wissen,
welche und deiner meisten, womit das das sieht.
Zum Kopfhals-Tumor, axillaer ist selten, da passt es nie, die bleiben oben.
Und bei gi tumo, es ist axillaer, sieht man fast nie, aber eher so ein Hals oben,
oder torakal.
Limfknoten sieht man eher, bei Magen kann man axillaer aufsehen,
und superklaviklaseen sieht man hals, aber hals ist auch selten,
aber eher, klar kann man auch sehen.
Bei Darm, selten oben zu sehen, aber sehen Sie aber,
wenn Sie Limfknoten, Hals und axillaer haben, dann ist es eher so
ein bisschen verdachtes Limfknoten.
Okay.
Und Mama Katsinom?
Mama Katsinom, ja, bei Frauen, da passt nicht.
Bei Frauen, das sollen Sie unbedingt denken, das ist richtig.
Und da muss es in Brustuntersuchung durchführen, auch hier.
Wenn das hin kommt, dann sollen Sie nicht schüchtern,
sich vollstellen oder lassen, dass Sie ja, Frau,
ich tasse nicht der Brust, das ist nicht gut, nein.
In Deutschland sollen Sie es machen.
Wenn das hin kommt, muss es dann egal, was Sie vermutig haben,
einfach nackt untersuchen.
Weil am Ende, wenn Sie das nicht gemacht haben,
kann sein, denn das hat sich beschwertet, und kommt hier,
der Arzt hat mir überhaupt nicht angeschaut,
der hat mich nicht meiner Brust getastet,
und sagt ja, warum?
Ja, weil der Ausländer ist.
Und deswegen machen Sie das.
Ja, auch wenn Passen sagt, ich will das nicht,
ja, trotzdem, wenn Sie Vermutung haben,
auch bei unklares Tour, dann sollen Sie überall untersuchen.
Manchmal sagen Sie, wenn Sie dann einfach
von oben fangen, bis unten, das ist halt so.
Weil ich muss an der Focus finden.
Bei Focus-Untersuchung, da gibt es keine Grenzen.
Ja, so ist das.
Sie haben es toll gemacht.
Die Gruppe ist auch toll, muss ich sagen.
Jeder ist aktiv und auch sehr erfahrend.
Aber Sie sprechen auch sehr gut, besser als meines.
Auch an einem, die sehen Sie auch sehr gut.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Sie den der Profi Deutsch waren.
Sie haben das geschafft.
Wo sind Sie denn?
Das ist ein Reiland-Pals.
Ja, das ist einfach ich glaube, das schafft man.
Weiß nicht.
Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Ich habe eine Frage,
wird in Deutschland nicht üblich durchgeführt?
Bei dem Form?
Ja, genau, bei dem Form, per Daft.
Was wollen Sie jetzt damit schauen?
Belast oder Link-Parschierung?
Ja, wenn Sie das Verdacht haben, dass Leute Chemie haben.
Den Form belast haben, natürlich, das machen Sie.
Aber am meisten ist das unsinnvoll.
Bei dem Form müssen Sie nicht.
Bei dem Form ist es Gold, Standard ist die Lymphkronung.
Wenn Sie ein Blutbild deiner Auffälligkeit sehen,
als Sie gesagt haben, bei Ihnen war nicht das Fall.
Wenn Sie eine Knochenmark-Suppression sehen,
da müssen Sie unbedingt ein Blut aus Schriftstürmen,
weil Sie wissen es nicht genau, woher kommt das.
Kann sein, dass eine Leute Chemie ist,
sondern eine Minder hat auch eine Immunsuppression.
Daraufhin hat eine Fiktion, hat eine Lymphkronung vergrößt.
Müssen Sie etwas schmeinen?
Ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, und daher, dann müssen Sie das machen.
Aber das ist selten bei Lymphkronung.
Das ist 15%, das ist so etwas sehen.
Das heißt, 85% haben unauffällig Blutbild.
So sehen Sie gar nichts außer LTH.
Und es ist sagen Sie, woher kommt das jetzt?
Blende Blutbild, aber hat eine Lymphkronung vergrößt.
Das ist ein typisches Blutbild.
Daher sollen sich nicht an die Blutbild verlassen.
Sie sollen die Mehrheit, die Patienten auch im Bogen behalten
und darauf hinaus reagieren.
Aber Sie haben recht, das kann man machen,
wie ich es gesagt habe,
und entsprechend, wenn Sie die Vermutung haben.
Und noch keine Frage, ne?
Ich habe eine Frage, aber nicht mit diesen Patienten.
Meine Frage sind, so ein Mal,
als es ist, was ist kleiner Blutbild
und was ist größer Blutbild?
Kann man Sie bitte...
Sehr genau, gut.
Eine gute Frage, ein kleines Blutbild, Sie haben keine Differenzierung.
Das heißt, da gibt es ein manuales Blutbild,
wo man den Differenzierung erfassen kann,
im Sinne von Sie sehen die Nettrophilenzahl,
die Lymphzügenzahl, Sie sehen, die war so viel in Zahl.
Ein kleines Blutbild, Sie haben diese drei nicht.
Vor allem die Nettrophilm oder die Lymphzügenzahl haben sie nicht drin.
Sie haben nur den Blutbild, die Lymphzügen,
die Hemoglobinenthromphzücken und Teil von also vielen
und der Rest auch.
Aber die Nettrophilm haben sie nicht drin,
die Lymphzügen haben sie auch nicht drin.
Das Besuch sagt man, macht man eine Differenz,
manuelles Blutbild, warum,
was ist denn manuelles Blutbild?
Es ist wie eine Großblutbild,
aber manuell macht man unter Metroskopie,
dann zählt man jedes Zählen.
Da sieht man den Reih von Grammysücken,
sozusagen den Lymphzügen, den Nettrophilm,
den Basophilm und alles, so zu sagen.
Da sieht man manuell.
Und bei Blutbild, das müssen Sie nicht manuell machen,
das macht die Maschine selbst.
Das ist eine automatische Blutbilddifferenzierung.
Ist das jetzt klar geworden?
Ja, und andere Frage,
was ist ein solches Parameter und gerinnungsparametrische?
Die Grinnungsparametre ist die Krieg,
die PTD und INR, das ist so standard,
ich glaube auch in der Türkei ist auch die Gleiche.
Die Grinnungsparametre, was man macht
und die Grinnungsparametre,
die Grinnungsparametre,
die Leukopinie,
das ist auch eine Zeichnung von der Grinnungsparametre,
wenn Sie Leukopinie haben,
das ist nicht, dass Sie keine Infektion haben.
Neutrophilm ist auch wichtig,
das ist sehr reaktiv Protein.
Und was noch, das ist Prokastitonin,
die man auch in Betracht nehmen soll,
falls man eine bakterielle Infektion ausschließen will.
Zum Beispiel,
die hat eine COPD von 200,
aber hat kein Infektzeichen.
Dann sagt man, was soll ich jetzt machen?
Die hat COPD von 200.
Sie haben keine Verlauf.
Prokastonin, wenn eine Prokastonin negativ ist
und man keine Klinik davor hat, dann sagen Sie,
es ist eine Tumusheppe, weil Tumuproduzien auch sehr päd.
Und da müssen Sie gar nicht darauf reagieren,
da müssen Sie einfach beobachten.
Aber wenn Sie Prokastonin positiv haben,
weil der sehr sensibel ist bei bakteriale Entziehungen,
dann müssen Sie dann antivirtisch anbehandeln.
Und in der Form gibt es
eine Zitopinik?
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn Sie eine Knochenmark zu Prüktion haben,
wenn die Knochenmark betroffen sind durch die Lymphom,
dann haben Sie natürlich Blutweltsturungen,
weil die Knochenmark nicht mehr produzieren kann.
Dann haben Sie Panzitopinik und sie auch haben.
Je nach welcher Reihe betroffen ist,
das ist auch wichtig,
und dann haben Sie diese Reihe dann entsprechend auch Probleme.
Das könnte auch nur eine Kupini sein,
auch nur Tromus-Kupini sein.
Daher müssen Sie gucken.
Aber in diesem Fall, da müssen Sie eine Knochenmark-Punktion machen.
Dann gehört das so.
Danke schön.
Noch Fragen?
Was machen wir jetzt?
Manmut, haben Sie zwei Falten?
Was haben Sie denn gemacht?
Ein weiterer Fall.
Haben Sie noch eine?
Wenn Sie noch eine, dann machen Sie es.
Dann machen Sie es.
Danke schön.